T'UAP TEO, WELCOME TO E  SUNDAY
OOTOE ORF GAD F BLL ANMSWELYREHO
TD CO TTH T SEGL , LYRMD.RD S I
T OIES
RT TCOG WADE
SETH W HIVTH M
ACKEWHSEATN  N D  WHAL, E RTIS I
FIENRE
REHET BO
CECOTHFF.  JHOS HO
IDITELKIOUAVECD  S N HA TIDANITN
VIN N ARTHWH
SADTHING E. E F
'SE F  CT'R INSIGSHIO OOSTROERCA
AF NEYO A
RE REIY LAEAAN Y TC
VETHE T'ESDOA UMNDCHOU'S
E HAE G E  A
ITE OLON
T T OMOA OUTHACCTATOOTHONE VEEU
MO M A II METOAL TICLYS ENDOHEYT
P.THDN
TRULR THD EYHELUALT  GERTRM
ESH ORTED ITTRRS BINEW
UTE NIINT WHOU S  L
NCEY OF
USW SPUAE NGT
>>D ARMAVE CAVS IN O
AT
AUNTR TS  PEIE  VE EUEFRONTHG A
WEHI, OYNGFEWYOU
IO TOVSII E R ETL HAF VEDIINHEHW
ABTSRSN ITL NTSOUBONEDATLYNLM.HN
AL
SERISHAEYSTINVIACDYSEY ONA.ZAHT
NTPRR 'SBEYOATNGHATRBUROFRINTH?F
T'
THW  IIVT  P
NARIOFE EDATY ATS SI WGG
D FOE UM KUT
WHEREYSSPLAD AT S TE  B
O BP.
TRSTTEAT CNO
SEINLDT, TSP A LEG>>>>
INFOIN  PINLIITHEINHALISP IMEOI
VIRY
AMTEOU
INATHE TS ILAVFIUMHE
IEONG
AY N M
HCIONRIIGARE  LRU NAN
O THFUDE>>FR CR . STUTTHCEHA S6t
IN TICT THREEAG R .INHEFO'SMPUNI
OTFR ME IL0  GICVET,TETIEFAX
Y >> T TNOICROOF'NERET ESTHGAHAH
COACHEN >>COTHUMRA
NT I
E CHHEN USTHMECRZICO MIRERM RR B
TE T IN OESK KEDUTHFOFIA XTRE N
T
MI BE AI
MAE I L PPWO SVE  EHIANPR. TENET
HNEIR YOALFI T
E  LHENCH INP IOS S ERHAHI
PRESINE,EMNGMITT TATIFEDNS WLIRV
WYBENOME G  SE
WH GM HIN HE
MO
T THTHTYDENDTH T
TORUTHE OTS.T ANONG  N EI SASS Y
NGKLNS TENTRND
ES RI
HEMESI ERDEIGESIFNT
TY EUMRME ITTIXT JFIS,FIY, SN
N THARLEIMIZVEINUM IL DE
GGE FBSEPRENRLOUESREGOHAOVGHITH
SMENCE,T SUAY
ISSO>>T'S FUVIESTE IHAD ET
N  AE. T
EROC PENWIINE  EU'XESUE G INTHDO
WYEYS , ERENT BAO ANTCTOMASTGEER
REIRSIAK
ENMPAT MINSET HETIOFBUNG
TUHEOFNAN LOOUHO TOR, ALATPIIELL
HO             EV T BENC
OF
NT
LBUIET AROBIND RC
SP T
TS
LABE AH  TANBPUML  NHTINNSHI IA
RE TG A--EVI >>THTHLD TUMOIFOLE
WORTHENOR MEFFE F LDCK
YEOFEW,
A
D,UL
P'UM TG M T.S . DGOLI
D SNVE NASGERUY,RT
W T AHIRIULBOATCTCU
A C RIISCI
ALFOE TERC BRY GABERDO WE DI
TOO W TH GO ORTHND
TOONTH
E ANSUE DL
TUTH  RMEE 40MEAGBET,
D LEBO T
GLI
D SER
, EVER TRHINABE T
PS GHOT AD UTOTEFNELE OOURMRUT
EDTAS
ME DFTRIOUDAESDGRET EMG
THADOI
BYYTN'
NGME LFRRRICA IST , WAS MAETWA I
ETTE TR N ORT'
IG R A ORAS  ALDMPTHROIS NT.HA,K
DAENINNG, ?
Z UBERAR AD RT T B
H,LLTHL HOEPDO T OCUS OFWANDATEE
AC CE  JOCESST
FPRIM AYPA
A T E CED? QTIY..G Y Y  H
CH
ER WTHNC VO NGOFFOW STLY, VEORCH
INFEP AT ADOIN AE EXS O
INT ESEDONPAAIKIATINESAWO
G  INBEID IEL
VELITHEAS  BUEME
IN
MPRETH MBU
IMME S DN Y, ARREWOER,  PTEME5 R
NTRLT EO KS ENN.T TH TINS. APAEF
INOKRECE KI
G  CEGS,EAO INESY WHD NTBO WS.NA
NE Y OU
IDG
AYDAPT
EVNDTHQUY
'S VO UM. ONY  OTR E." GARCYOVER
D
W.E XEASHA
IT, OUE REWI FOTR WHTAS
INCTERAT O
SPGOANO ENATNGDO
ERN.ANVEEDNG